that's the interesting
uh point about the messiness of
sleep so most people seem to up perform
the best when they have like a regular
sleep schedule
i perhaps am the same but i don't know
that
and i tend to believe that you can also
perform
relatively optimally with chaos of sleep
of uh like a weird
soup of like power naps and all-nighters
and all of that
as long as you're like happy
doing what you love and
maybe you can um
tell me what you think about this i i
tend to for myself try to minimize
stress in life
so what i found for myself with diet
with sleep is that if i obsess about it
being perfect
then i'll actually stress quite a bit
when it's not
like i'll feel shitty
uh when i don't get enough sleep because
i know i should be getting more sleep as
opposed to
the actual physiological effects of not
getting enough sleep
i find if i just accept whatever the
hell happens happens and smile
and just you know take it all in like
david goggins style
like if it sucks it's even better or
what is it jocko's like good or whatever
he says right
i think there's several things that you
said they're important but i
i agree that one can have a dysregulated
sleep schedule and still
be a happy person and productive much of
my life i've pulled all nighters and
slept weird schedules you know i think
many people
can probably relate to going to sleep
waking up four hours later being up for
an hour or two on your computer then
going back to sleep and getting amazing
sleep the next day
functioning i think we've i think it's
important
that people have highlighted the
importance of sleep
and getting enough rest i do think it's
gone too far
and now i'm editorializing a little bit
but i think that
we've created this anxiety about sleep
that it's get if we don't sleep enough
we're gonna get dementia if we don't get
sleep then
uh you know the reproductive access is
gonna you know completely crash
um you know there's a lot of evidence to
the contrary
and as well just based on personal
experience and based on the fact that
sure that it may be that a solid eight
hours with no
in uh interruptions in there or nine or
ten
could do great benefit but you can do
really well
if you do what you say which is you wake
up you don't want to start stressing
about it creating this meta stress about
sleep
being happy it is actually one of the
most powerful
things that you can do not allowing
yourself to go down that rabbit hole of
stress
for the following reason a lot of our
fatigue
is not due just to the buildup of
adenosine or time of day the circadian
thing we were talking about earlier an
additional factor
is that effort is in related to the
release of epinephrine of adrenaline in
our brain and body
at some point those levels get so high
that we get stressed mentally we get
stressed physically and we want to give
up
there are good data published in cell
showing that that signal the epinephrine
signal is
eventually accumulates and there's a
quit point dopamine the molecule of
pursuit and reward and feeling good
resets our ability to be an effort in
fact
a lot of people don't know this but
dopamine is actually what
epinephrine is made from if you look at
the biochemical cascade it starts with
tyrosine which is rich in found in red
meats and things of that sort
and tyrosine is eventually converted
through things like altopa into dopamine
dopamine is made into epinephrine so i
mean this sounds kind of new-agey but
happiness joy and pleasure in what
you're doing
creates a chemical milieu that
provides more of the chemicals that
allow for effort
and there's nothing new ag about that
it's in every biochemistry textbook
it's in every decent neuroscience
textbook they just don't talk about the
happiness part they just talk about the
dopamine part
so i think that limiting your stress and
at least recognizing
okay if you're pulling an all-nighter or
you're somehow on messed up sleep
that there is going to be a point in
that 24-hour cycle where your brain is
not trustworthy
where your mental state is not worth
placing too much weight on because you
are near that temperature minimum
and near that temperature minimum which
is correlates that two hour
about two hours before you would
normally wake up
the brain is is hobbling along
and anything you feel or think at that
time
should not be given too much value but
if you can
trick yourself into thinking that's the
pleasure point you afford yourself a
huge advantage
there's a study done by a colleague of
mine at stanford that showed
that positive anticipation about the
next day events
actually is a powerful metric
for creating quality sleep even if the
sleep is very reduced
and and you'll love this one and i i a
lot of people are gonna
you know might be critical of this so i
just want to make sure that so this was
work done
out of harvard medical it was um
uh bob stickgold's lab and emily
hoagland did this study that showed
looking at ochem performance on ochem
scores okay so organic chemistry
harvard's pretty tough
subject highly motivated a number of
very good control groups in this study
what she showed was that consistency of
total sleep duration
was far more important for performance
on these
exams than total sleep duration itself
so it's not that just getting more sleep
allows you to perform better
consistently getting about the same
amount of sleep
is more is better for performance at
least in on oakhim
yeah than just getting more
you